ein mann ruft die schädlingsbekämpfer
und bekommt eine hammer rechnung
präsentiert 2200 euro soll er zahlen ja
das ist dreister abzocke anders kann man
das nicht nennen
wir zeigen ihnen jetzt worauf sie achten
müssen damit sie nicht auf solche
betrüger hereinfallen handwerker abzocke
im internet mit professionell aussehen
den webseiten und google werbung locken
betrüger kunden in die falle
sie versprechen schnellen günstigen
handwerker service zu jeder zeit
doch wenn sie kommen fordern sie oft
wucherpreise sie erledigen arbeiten
fehlerhaft oder gar nicht
wir haben uns jetzt mal eine betrüger
webseite angeschaut klempner 24 jahren -
hilfe.de die kam wenn man ein klempner
berlin zum beispiel bei google eingab
unter den ersten beiden ergebnis nur ein
erfahrungsgemäß und dass die wo die
leute drauf klicken wenn man sich diese
webseite anschaut auf den ersten blick
sieht die einigermaßen professionell aus
dort sind einige stop bilder
es werden faire preise versprochen wenn
jedoch diese von dieser webseite
vermittelten fachleute bei den kunden
zuhause zu hause aus schlugen forderten
sie fantasiepreise von 500 bis 1000 euro
für nichtstun und wichtig ist es keine
kein impressum zu finden keine adresse
man kann diesen leuten nicht mehr
habhaft werden
adam tessmer ein ausgebildeter und
fairer bettwanzen jeder kennt das
problem genau tessmer und seine ferien
kollegen treffen immer wieder auf
ausgenommene kunden das schlimmste war
fall war ein älterer herr dem betrüger
2000 euro vom konto über die ec-karte
abgezogen haben und 200 euro bar bei
ausführungen der nicht fachgerechten
dienstleistung
letztes jahr hat google deutschland
weiter werbung für schlüsseldienste
verboten diese dürfen jetzt nur noch
regional geschaltet werden
somit haben sich die verbrecher auf
andere branchen ausgebreitet die
betrüger benutzen häufig die gleiche
telefonnummer für vollkommen
verschiedene webseiten und tätigkeiten
wenn man dann noch diese hätte diese
handynummer bei google eingibt kommt man
auf viele verschiedene gewerke auf
schädlingsbekämpfung rohrreinigung die
alle unter dieser nummer laufen ist also
verschiedene gewerke die von diesen
betrügern ausgenutzt
und bei mir im studio ist jetzt peter
welke du wurdest auch fast abgezockt was
ist denn da genau passiert ja also es
war bei mir schon hier im februar hier
in berlin da hatte ich ein rohrbruch bei
dem waschbecken unter bei mir im
badezimmer
das war freitags abends kurz vom
wochenende da natürlich kein handwerker
arbeitet deswegen eine kleine
notsituation
ich habe dann im internet gegoogelt nach
notdienst klempner und bin auch ein
bisschen naiv dann direkt auf die erste
anzeige gegangen habe eben bei so einer
handynummer angerufen und da kamen dann
innerhalb von einer stunde ein junger
mann vor bei der ich war ein bisschen
irritiert schon hat sich aufgemacht
haben der tut nämlich einen sehr edlen
gucci jogginganzug hatte schwarzen
sneakern und sah es überhaupt nicht nach
handwerker aus hätte dann noch ein
klemmbrett dabei und finden dann auch
schon direkt an über seine immensen
preise zu reden wollte dann insgesamt
560 euro dafür haben um dieses einfache
rohr zu wechseln was man schon ab 10 uhr
baumarkt bekommt und habe ich ihm dann
auch gesagt wieder in dieser hohe preis
zustande kommen würden meinte er
eben weil er so spät gekommen ist wollte
er noch 100 prozent spielt zum schlag
haben materialkosten also alles
vollkommen absurd und weil wir eben zu
zweit waren mit meinem mitbewohner der
frau konnten wir dann noch erreichen
dass er dann gegangen ist dann wollte er
noch 50 euro anwaltskosten haben aber
das kommt mir alles verhindern
also ist noch mal gut ausgegangen das
war schon ziemlich auch so und was rät
zu anderen dass sie eben nicht auf
solche betrüger hereinfallen ja
grundsätzlich erstmal überhaupt nicht
auf solche google-anzeigen anspringen
sind echt gefährlich weil die betrüger
zahlen eben an google geld das sie ihre
webseiten da ganz oben platzieren wenn
man sucht und dann darauf kommt diese
webseiten sehen eben auch erst sehr gut
aus wir gerade gesehen haben
aber da sind auch typische anzeichen und
dann direkt erkennen kann dass das
betrüger sind es gibt eben nur
handynummern kein impressum oder häufig
verwenden die betrüger auch einfach
adressen von anderen handwerksbetrieben
beispielsweise in berlin geben die an
aber da muss man halt vorher checken ist
das jetzt wirklich der handwerker der
auch da arbeitet an dieser adresse weil
man vergebens falsche adressen hat daran
kann man das erstmal an der webseite
erkennen und am besten ist einfach
direkt über den vermieter zu nehmen den
nach einem möglichen handwerker zu
fragen
das ist also dann tipp quasi wie man den
richtigen handwerker finden oder kann
man auch trotzdem im internet einen
guten finden man kann im internet finden
oft hilfreich ist auch dass man so
schaut gibt es da so eine kategorie über
uns sind da wirklich menschen mit dem
firmenlogo auf dem pullover oder so zu
sehen weil auf diesen betrüger seiten
die haben auch ganz abstruse namen wie
halten klempner 24 also nicht sagen
keine familiennamen oder sonst was von
dem entsprechenden handwerkern dann kann
man das halt auch erkennen und man kann
über das internet gehen aber am besten
ist immer der weg erst mal über den
vermieter weil er eben grundsätzlich
verpflichtet dazu ist ein mangel zu
beseitigen da kann man dann auch direkt
mit dem vermieter sprechen wäre das am
ende zahl der kindheit die
entsprechenden handwerker die er dann an
stellt und wenn man selbst haus oder
wohnungsbesitzer ist dann ist es auch
immer gut wenn man noch das alte telefon
murat da sind wirklich echte handwerker
drin oder über nachbarn sonst bis zu
gehen